the company's performance the entire
company's performance
is influenced by their founder
psychology
by the founder's mental state by the
founders personality
by the team cohesiveness but the team
fitness
where are we at right now the company is
constantly
influenced by that and the business
result is influenced by that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
in running a startup it may not always
just be that analytical thinking or
decision making that makes you succeed
or fail
a lot of it is about the partnership
it's about the journey the process
meet noah matz operating partner at f2
venture capital
noi is an operating partner at f2 she
has dedicated her career to
understanding startup founding team
dynamics and coaching founders for peak
performance
she is an expert in performance
enhancement and coaching for startup
teams and executives
guiding them through change to take
high-risk decisions in stressful and
uncertain conditions
no matter welcome to 20 minute leaders
welcome thank you
how are you doing i'm great we're in the
beautiful f2 capital offices
exactly back in the office back at the
office yeah post covered
operating partner startup psychologist
right
before we even get to your journey what
does that even mean both operating
partner
and startup psychologists i don't know
either okay so startup psychologist
is is a is a branding it's a form of me
myself branding
what i do sense and
training i'm a social psychologist and
in the past few years
i've been i became an expert in the
psychology of startups
each psychologist has his own niche yes
what you were having to ask something it
started with psychologists of startups i
know psychologists of people i love from
going to a psychologist but what does it
mean
psychologist of startups it means that
the
founders psychology is
crucial for startup success and we in f2
we understand that and we constantly say
that fact the the company's performance
the entire company's performance
is influenced by their founder
psychology by the founder's mental state
by the founder's personality by the team
cohesiveness but
the team fitness where are we at right
now the company is constantly
influenced by that and the business
result is influenced by that
so as a startup psychologist i have two
main now operating operating partner as
well
i have two main jobs goals
pre-investment and post-investment
pre-investment is to get to know very
very well the founders in which we
invest
and allow them to know us before an
investment
and also post-investment which is the
fun
most um rewarding
aspect of my work is to
walk this path with our founders
be their sounding board their first
phone call whatever you
like to call it when things go wrong but
also when things are just growing
and they need a people person so we can
talk about this more
so i i do know that you know in the due
diligence process especially in early
stage
the team is everything right you want to
see the cohesiveness you want to see the
founder mentality
the resilience i mean i'm not too aware
of what happens post
the investment so so i get that you're
an integral part of the due diligence
but then how do you
actually work with the company's post
investment to help maintain
the strong cohesiveness and resilience
okay so first i need to build the trust
and the relationship
the bond with the founders because
it's not um it's not something that
easy or trivial right it's not trivial
to to have those kind of conversation
with your investor
to get to know your investor and have
your investor get to know you
to those kind of levels so first we need
to build the trust and the communication
and we start by talking about the future
about the vision about building the team
about the objective uh results
things that are more tangible and not as
soft and then we build our relationships
for months for sometimes years and then
we get to a point where
when things go wrong or whether they
have a big dilemma
or when they have an issue with their
co-founders or when
they have a managerial dilemma which
happens every day or
where they have some kind of difficulty
or challenge with their investor could
be
one of my partners because they could
also happen then they will come to me
and we'll try to fix it together we will
try to talk about it
and understand the problem look at the
problem from different angles
put a question mark on this problem is
it a problem
is this problem what i thought it is do
i have
do i actually do have the tools to deal
with this problem although i thought i
didn't have or for for example let's
give a tantable example
we're in the middle of a founding round
we want to
raise our a round and then we got
churned by a customer i currently have
four customers
and one of them churned it's 25 churn
now that could be a very very stressful
event for a for a founder
and now the question mark that we need
to put on this situation is allow him
to to re to rephrase it is this the end
of my career is this the end
of this startup because now we got 25
churn it's it's a it's a big problem no
doubt
right but we will have to rephrase it
in order for him or her to be able to
deal with this problem
what i'm hearing you say is that there's
one layer
of looking at things very analytically
one customer turned oops 25
churn rate that's not good but what
you're saying actually there's there's a
many more layers to the to this event
that's happening
and you're also raising question marks
saying is this actually
why did they turn maybe is this you know
relevant actually to
to is this actually a part of the
statistic maybe it's an anomaly
or maybe the way that you're thinking
about this as a founder shouldn't
prohibit you from moving on and waking
up tomorrow with the same energy
mentality
and that's where the psychology enters
right right so the psychology of the
founder when he steps in the room that
his mindset
is of challenge
yeah the skies falling uh
it's um we're not gonna make it
this this one i'm not gonna be able to
solve this is too much
that's that's it 25 churn in the middle
of founding round this is not something
where
we can solve right my job is to help him
exit the room
feeling that okay i i can deal with it
i can deal with it i we didn't fix the
problem
but we fixed his mindset so now he feels
like he's able to deal with it
now i'm guessing that a lot of the times
founders don't even feel comfortable
expressing these emotions and kind of
let alone their investors
right who might join the next round who
might bring on the next investors
right so i guess one of the challenges
here is you have to build that trust
so that they feel comfortable in your
office expressing those difficult
emotions which i'm sure that everybody
has we just don't talk about it right
right that's true so with previous
investments i've been with this fund
with f2 for three years as an external
consultant
when i had my own team diligent my own
company i used to give
um consultancy services to vcs and
startups in the past
few months now i've been officially
full-time part of the fund i'm a partner
in the fund
so in new investments
i feel like it's easier because i get to
build a relationship
with our founders from day one right and
i get to give them the sense from day
one that this is your home
this is where you can throw chairs at
each other
this is where you can cry this is where
you can fight this is where
you can say i'm weak today this is where
you can take off the mask
you can be yourself we don't judge you
vice versa
we know it's there so you might as well
just talk about it and let's
let's help you i'm not sure if solving
it but
let's help you get to to an emotional
space where you can deal with the world
so now it's easier for me with previous
investments
that i wasn't officially part of the
fund and
some investment that i wasn't even here
at all when we took them it was much
much more challenging because you have
to change your relationship halfway
right building it from the foundation up
exactly um
exactly so now it's it's way easier and
much more natural for everyone now i i
know quite a quite a few vc's by now and
i don't think i came across many startup
psychologists or or this
figure within a venture capital fund but
it makes perfect sense to me
you want them to feel comfortable you
want them to be a part and and to feel
that they can share the information
because it also helps you
help them right why is this not a common
thing
right why so you've touched an
interesting point when you say
the older generation of vcs
is there's this
um how do you say distance in hebrew
it's distance like in in the middle
there's a distance between the investor
and the founder right there's a game to
be played yeah to be played
and we all play the game of smiling
and happy faces and all is good in the
world
and we um
we share what we need to share even even
if we lose if we fail if the numbers are
not good enough
we don't have choice we need to share it
in the board hoping that it's not going
to do too much of a damage to us
that's i feel like that's the old world
that's the old school
the new age of venture capitalists
is understanding that this is not going
to work
or it's gonna look work much better
much more efficient much more successful
if we're gonna just go we're just gonna
put it out there and talk
the truth what is really going on in the
world what is regarding your world
in your soul in your company and
i think this is the trend and we're
gonna start seeing this i'm pretty
unique
we do have it for example in the u.s
there is a
fund code called coastal ventures they
have an operating partner which
he used to be a ceo um i forgot his name
i'm sorry he used to be
he was an operator he wasn't uh he's not
a psychologist or
he's not a mental health expert but he
his um job is to
to do what i do but he's not a
psychologist like he used to he's a
previously ceo and
he also have his own companies is now
he's he came he's coming here to
do to work with the companies to work
with the founders right
but a mental health specialist that's
not
very common to have right do you expect
it to become more common let's say we
think five ten years down the line
definitely most definitely
i see how much traction um i'm getting
uh psychologists they want to step into
this world from here and from
the world and how much investors are
interesting to understand what i'm how i
what am i doing and how can they do it
in their funds
right so yes definitely and and and it's
needed
right it's needed now you you did a
master's in in social psychology
back then did you know that you're
you're destined to join one of the one
of the top
vcs here in israel is this was this like
the the grand plan for noah
yeah well definitely one of the best
israeli vc funds most definitely that's
first
now after we got that right um
no i i didn't know that but
i followed my intuition which i do quite
often
and i followed my strengths and i took
some
could seem strange decisions just the
person from the outside
give me one to launch a business
at age of how old was i 26
7. out of out of the masters out of the
masters
yeah it's not a very common thing to do
no i had
experience but not experienced as a
business owner
and it has so many meanings to it so
many responsibilities to it
not only being a psychologist you have
to know how to do many other things
and i always followed my intuition and
my gut
i didn't know this is what i'm going to
do but i always knew that i have to
combine
business and psychology in some way i
always knew that i'm not the kind of
psychologist that can sit in the same
chair same sofa all day which i'm not
and that's amazing for me that i have
the freedom to be creative and move and
not be dynamic and choose what i want to
do every day we moved four rooms until
we got here i can
see that it happens a lot here because
we have so many people here all the time
the f2 environment is such an
environment that allows you to be who
you are
trust you to be the best version of
yourself
bring them as much value to the fund as
you can
and it's it's such a privilege to be
part of this this
home this family so speaking now to
founders yeah early stage stage
a lot of my friends are our founders
okay
i see the struggle as a friend i sit
with him for a beer and i can sin
yeah and it is something that i've been
contemplating why
you know who do you talk to about this
like i i don't know anything i
i can't really help you much but why
don't you talk to your investors or or
you know or
design partners and they're scared what
what what tips could you give them or or
some insight now that you're seeing the
work with a lot of founders
what could the average founder do to to
to help make them feel a little bit
better with this
wow um first
obviously the the way you choose your
partners
the vc fund that you
chosen your partners your co-founders
the first employees always
um prefer to have someone that is like
you
that you trust that you have chemistry
with that you enjoy work with
over the best talent interesting over
the best professional talent
always prefer that many times i see that
founders tend to say okay this is just
he is a
super talent he's gonna get this product
from here to here in two months
i'm gonna take him over this person that
is not
such a super talent superstar but
i we feel each other we love working
together
this is much more beneficial
to your startup and team over this
person
marathon not as friends exactly right
now when it comes to choosing
the vcs i mean yeah you get a term sheet
from a vc that has a great name
it's it's very you know i i can i can
feel the endorphins in the dopamine
even though i don't have a term i
can already feel how how it might feel
like
it's very tempting to to go for the best
name in the best brand even if you don't
have good chemistry with a partner
right do you actually think that it's
feasible to tell a founder no no you
should actually go for
a lower tier vc that is more like you
and and can be more of a friend
so i'm not sure if a friend is the right
way to
phrase it because many times
we're we're not friends specifically
joni and bach that
take board seats in our companies
they're not friends of their founders
but they're here for them
they they give them the advice that they
need they guide them
so they're not friends but they're like
mentors or
right i think something that's more
accurate um what was the question i'm
sorry
maybe that helps make them feel you know
comfortable with making decisions that
you know don't conform to the stress of
of you know what the techcrunch articles
are saying or you know i i have to get
to yc
because that means that i'm worth
something well maybe that's not the
right place for me but but
society tells me i have to go there okay
right
so how do i as a founder you know
breathe and deal with this
stress and maybe take the non-so common
route and maybe go for somebody
who's not as top-tier or as noticeable
but is the right partner for me so
fomo is one of the psychological biases
that are
very strong in vc right that if there's
like a
hot deal out there
then we all want to see this hot deal
and it creates fomo and
and then the valuation of the company
rises
etc and that this influences the
founders
obviously and
i would suggest the founders to try to
get to know
the partners to get to know the
investment team to get to know the fund
the fun
team members to try to sense the energy
in the office
to have reference calls without the vc
definitely we always suggest
and we also make the connections choose
whoever you want to talk to choose
whoever photo you want to talk to
we'll connect it you to him and or to
her and
you i mean sure you have to you have to
d
on your investor you usually can't
choose your partner
i mean who from the partners will sit in
your board
uh but you can definitely choose the
fund
and it's very important to
valuation is obviously
a significant aspect in your investment
process
but if don't choose because of the
valuation
choose for the people choose for the
partners don't choose for valuation
just because one fund gives you higher
valuation doesn't mean you have to
choose this fund
yeah what is something that you learned
over your i guess
three years at f2 that is not trivial
that something about maybe it's about
the relationship between founders and
their partners of their employees
something about the psychology of an
entrepreneur that now in hindsight he
said wow i
i didn't think this is how it works the
psychology of an entrepreneur the
psychology of people
you choose um
the you we read it in books yeah
that and we hear it from great managers
that talk about
how to allow creativity with your people
how to allow people to
the freedom to to dream to work to
execute
and and i see it firsthand
today the way johnny and barack are
managing the fund
uh i could actually see
what does it mean to be a manager that
allows people to walk their own walk
even if it's not your specific walk
it's their walk and they're doing this
walk very well let them be
the significance of allowing employees
people team members to bring their own
true self to bring their own creativity
if you've chosen them
and you trust them and they provide
value
and they're good professionals let them
be
and don't i mean don't don't um
this hug bear yeah don't do that yeah
don't micromanage
let them be themselves so that's that's
something that that i've learned here
over the years and i've seen it
firsthand no i have a few questions
about you yeah talking about psychology
we talked about f2 i have questions
about no amounts
it's going to be weird but but they're
important okay
your favorite subject yeah from middle
school or
high school can well
um that's kind of that's kind of lame
but it was psychology really all the way
back to middle school and high school
middle school is like aleph yeah i guess
yeah so yeah
we didn't take aliphat so i hated math i
hated man
i like literature and then when we could
take the like
internships uh so it was psychology
amazing
yeah sorry who would be a a role model
somebody that inspires you in some way
in this world
yeah um do you have time to think
yeah i'll think about it because there
are plenty
well actually this is a weird
answer but music calms me down since i'm
a very uh sensitive person
i get energy i get emotions of other
people in the room
i get things that i don't need to take
things that are
useless for me but it's just the way it
is so music
um helps me to like cut myself from the
world and
re recalibrate and
and the best person the best music
artists um that does that for me is
every day
really so wow i like he's my person
yeah he's my person he watches every
episode
exactly and uh the last question what
are three words that if i would ask you
about yourself
yeah who is noah matt yeah well what
characterizes you
well i'm uh i'm a free spirit
okay i'm a butterfly my husband got this
butterfly for me and i
is it's who i am
and i'm very energetic and i'm very
sensitive
butterfly energetic and sensitive
[Music]